today on game life we go deep inside the
brain of Greg Kasavin creative director
of the new game transistor so if you
like Bastion you will not be able to
contain yourself so there has been one
supergiant game essentially you guys
came out of nowhere in 2011 with this
game it captivated people it was it was
an arcade release and then it kind of
proliferated but now you're coming back
and so supergiant second game is coming
when early next year with any luck with
any luck and it's called transistor yeah
that's right now I got to play the game
Penny Arcade Expo out in Boston yeah
sorry about them one day I think you
guys had the longest line at Penny
Arcade Expo that was crazy to us yeah we
did not know what to expect going into
that show other than like okay we're
gonna announce this thing and we're
gonna let people play it cuz we feel
very strongly that we want to let people
get their hands on it you know an event
like pax we didn't know quite how people
are gonna take it cuz you know with
Bastion we no one had ever heard of us
but this time around we didn't know what
at what all people's expectations were
gonna be around it and so forth but the
response we got was really really
terrific
well the vibe that I was getting was
very much like it was almost sort of
like parasite eve or like or like
fallout in the sense of it looks like an
action game you're running around in
there's enemies you could if you wanted
to it'd just go up for those enemies to
circle the sword and killing them but
that would that would really result in
your death but the new is you you kind
of like semi pause the action and plot
out a series of strategic moves and then
unpause and let it all take place yeah
exactly we wanted this like more
thoughtful experience where the combat
could have sort of an app and a flow to
it it's not just like you go in and you
know
disaster happens and the dust settles
and everybody's dead that's kind of when
we felt like we were onto something
it felt very powerful and since we
wanted to tell the story about this kind
of powerful object that you discover
it's like well it should grant you some
sort of extraordinary ability early on
and yeah people you know responded
really well to it well
weird game I mean it's very it's very
hard to describe what genre it goes into
if Bastion was our take on on like a
fantasy themed world and this is our
take on science fiction it's a game that
we also consider to be in the same genre
as Bastion like an action RPG but this
time around there's much more of a focus
on like this more strategic combat
system in comparison to our first game
we want to make a world that's kind of
filled with mystery you know hopefully
we intrigue the player very early on and
then we're kind of answering a lot of
questions as we go we're very interested
in synthesizing gameplay and
storytelling as closely as possible so
let's talk about your origin story yeah
as your editor in chief of GameSpot for
quite a while so what what within you
you know kind of like prompted to switch
over yeah from editorial to game making
I've been playing games like since my
earliest memories oh she always loved
them yep
I always wanted to make them and from
time to time I would I would try I would
like to try to learn the programming and
I would like I just hit a wall but yeah
I mean I'd be the same fan I was when I
was young I was like oh people make
video games I'm gonna make a video game
yeah and then discovered when I was like
13 oh wait Oh game then I realized if I
just wrote articles about video games
that was way easiest you could get a
whole article done in the time it would
take you to do like one you know one
thousandth of a video game yeah so at
that point I kind of just switched over
entirely that's very that's very similar
to my case thankfully a friend of mine
who I previously worked with that game
spot he knew I had this long-term
interest and he was a producer at
Electronic Arts and they were looking
for a new one
at the time he's like are you still
interested and I said yes and I applied
and I got it so I went and worked on the
command & Conquer realtime strategy
games for a while I was a TA for about
three years
that's where I met Amir and Gavin who
are the co-founders of supergiant we
work together on red alert 3 and and
stuff like that and command conqueror 3
before it we all quit around the same
time they formed supergiant I went to 2k
they just dropped everything and moved
into a house and start making Bastion
yeah about a year later I was I was able
to join them and yes that's where I am
now yeah yeah
and now again you are in a much better
position than than you were when you
were launching Bastion because you
you've got this hit behind you and you
can do something a little crazier you
know I mean obviously you don't want
this to become your Duke Nukem Forever
right well it's like we under the name
we don't intend to yeah I don't think
it's gonna take us quite that long
exactly we've never like worked on a
game where people had you know high
expectations as opposed to having no
expectations but now people kind of know
what we're up to they think they know
what we're all about so right you have
to surprise them yet again news I think
surprise is very very important to just
having a positive experience with a game
it needs to keep surprising you so so
yeah well we'll have to see yeah we
could do that again but as they say you
have your whole life to write your first
piece and after that you're on deadline
between Peter and myself our rolodex
does not stop at Gregg cassava here so I
mean we we know a lot of people in the
video game industry so let us know who
you want to see on game life it your
favorite video game developer could show
up on a future show or your favorite
developer could be Gregg in which case
just stop watching